zum vierten mal der sieg in folge bei
allen masc wettbewerb space 600 pot
competition die hyper loop kapsel vom
heimclub forschungsteam der technischen
universität münchen
langfristig könnten wir damit die
strecke berlin-hamburg in nicht einmal
20 minuten zurücklegen und an dieser
vision wird ganz konkret gearbeitet
jetzt hat auch saudi arabien den bau
eines hyperlinks verkündet und zwar in
einer komplett neuen stadt die sich
derzeit noch im aufbau befindet klicks
um science-fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen und ein riesen
dankeschön für diesen super spannenden
themen vorschlag den mehr petra
niedermeier über unsere telegramm
community geschickt hat laut ihren musk
ist es das verkehrsmittel der zukunft
mit dem man nahezu so schnell wie der
schall reisen kann in seiner
zukunftsvision von august 2013
beschreibt der sogenannte bots das sind
quasi fahrzeuge mit dem sitz angebot von
großraumtaxis die mit hoher
geschwindigkeit durch röhren rasen in
denen ein teil vakuum herrscht die
fahrzeuge könnten von einem linear
induktions motor angetrieben werden und
auf eine art magnet kissen schweben so
könnten geschwindigkeiten von bis zu
1200 kilometern pro stunde erreicht
werden und uns rasend schnell zwischen
zwei metropolen hin und her
transportieren mit dem hyper loop werden
wir schneller unterwegs als mit dem
flugzeug und es wird noch besser
durch das so genannte teil vacuum gibt
es kaum luftwiderstand wodurch kaum noch
energie für diese art von transport
benötigt wird solarzellen auf den
transporteuren könnten ausreichend seien
auch deutschland ist im halbfinale 2018
wurde bekannt dass auch in den hamburger
hafen ein hyper luft kommen soll
da geht es um science-fiction haben wir
ja darüber berichtet die kapseln könnten
durch computergesteuerte kräne mit
containern beladen werden laut plan
könnten dann pro tag bis zu 4100
container zu einer station im hamburger
umland geschossen werden das hätte
enorme vorteile für die hansestadt die
waren würden schneller zugestellt und
zudem würde die feinstaubbelastung
innerhalb der stadt durch den wegfall
von lkw enorm reduziert werden denn die
lkw würden dann dort aussah
der stadt die container abholen aber
jetzt auch saudi arabien hat neue pläne
bezüglich eines hyperlinks
veröffentlicht das us amerikanische
unternehmen virgin von richard branson
soll dort eine teststrecke in einer
komplett neuen stadt aufbauen die rede
ist von king abdullah economic city nach
angaben des unternehmens selbst wurden
bereits pläne zum bau eines forschungs
und entwicklungszentrums sowie einer
produktionsstätte unterzeichnen
vorgesehen ist demnach eine 35 kilometer
lange teststrecke die damit alle
bisherigen haimerl oberen übertreffen
würde doch die king abdullah economic
city wird gerade erst hochgezogen sie
wurde 2005 gegründet und entsteht etwa
100 kilometer nördlich der hafenstadt
dschidda am roten meer die infrastruktur
so langfristig für bis zu zwei millionen
einwohner ausgelegt werden die stadt ist
teil eines entwicklungsprojektes mit
dessen hilfe sich saudi arabien
unabhängig vom öl machen will
und da kommt ein hyper loop gerade recht
laut dem delegationsleiter mohan und
heller könnte er als eine art
katalysator für einen saudischen silicon
valley effekt sorgen denn nicht nur die
fertigungsindustrie sondern auch die
software entwicklung und die high tech
forschung könnten dadurch einen
aufschwung erhalten langfristig hat
saudi arabien das ziel mit dem bau eines
hyperlinks verschiedene länder zu
verbinden wie beispielsweise oman kuwait
und die vereinigten arabischen emirate
von riad nach in jeddah könnten güter
und fracht aber auch passagiere dann
statt in zehn stunden in nur 76 minuten
geladen
die reisezeit von riad nach abu dhabi
würde sich von achteinhalb stunden auf
48 minuten verkürzen
das us unternehmen virgin hyper lubahn
von virgin chef richard branson ist
alles andere als ein neuling auf dem
gebet in der wüste von nevada betreibt
ist derzeit eine 500 meter lange
teststrecke
doch von dem langfristigen ziel einmal
geschwindigkeiten von bis zu 1200
kilometern pro stunde zu erreichen sind
die aktuellen systeme noch weit entfernt
doch an dieser stelle kommt wieder ihren
maske ins spiel denn der unternehmer
hatte zwar die revolutionäre idee für
dieses potenzielle verkehrsmittel der
zukunft doch die hat er frei gegeben im
klartext heißt es also jeder darf einen
hype entwickeln und bauen und genau das
passiert derzeit weltweit und das senkt
die hürden zur rallye
die jungen natürlich ändern so existiert
ein weiteres test und forschungszentrum
mit einer 300 meter langen teststrecke
auch in südfrankreich dazu dirk kall
born der ceo von hyper lud
transportation technology blut geht es
um mehr als schnelle beschleunigung und
das brechen von geschwindigkeitsrekorden
es ist eine echte chance ein effizientes
und sicheres system mit einem
einzigartigen erlebnis für die reisenden
zu erschaffen und auch ihren maß selbst
ist nicht ganz raus aus dem thema er
veranstaltet jedes jahr die space hyper
laut pott competition für dieses jahr
wurde gerade der sieger gekürt zum
vierten mal handelt es sich um ein
deutsches team von der tu münchen
diese high club kapsel schaffte dieses
jahr fehler 63 kilometer pro stunde und
ist damit im wettbewerb die schnellste
weltweit eigentlich haben die fachleute
aus münchen sogar eine geschwindigkeit
von 600 kilometern pro stunde angepeilt
und geschafft außerhalb des wettbewerbs
hatten sich schon 482 kilometer pro
stunde doch eine bremse des potts
verhakte sich dieses mal und der belag
riss ab dazu teammanager tony jukic
vermutlich hätten wir sogar noch
deutlich schneller als 4 182 kilometer
pro stunde sein können jetzt hat die
hamas verkündet dass er die bedingungen
für seinen wettbewerb verändern will
die strecke wird ab dem nächsten jahr
nicht mehr gerade sein und zudem auch
deutlich länger als bisher
der vakuum tunnel wer dem jahr 2020 also
nicht nur eine kurve haben sondern sogar
zehn kilometer lang sein die bisherigen
wettbewerbe fanden den graben röhren
stadt die übrigens lediglich 1,25
kilometer lang waren unglaublich wie
schnell sie hier die technik
fortentwickelt und jetzt kommt die mini
heico fortbewegungsmittel der zukunft
einfach selber bauen wie das geht zeigt
euch der kanal breaking lab also
unbedingt anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
vor allem geht auf dem kanal im moment
immer mehr ab also bis dann abonnieren
angucken bis dann bleibt dran